CARLA HAYDEN: Oh, it's on.
Hello.
Hi.
I'm Carla Hayden with the Library of Congress
and it's great to see all of you and we're
almost ready to start so we thought we'd get
some warm up stuff going and this young lady
is going to do some stuff.
[pause]
SASHA: Hello Hello.
My name is Sasha.
I'm with the Young Readers Center.
We're downstairs and if you haven't been there,
come visit us.
LADY IN RED: I'm also at the Young Readers
Center.
SASHA: Yeah, so we're going to sing a song
about the Young Readers Center.
Do you guys know what an abbreviation is?
Ok.
So YRC stands for?
Yeah, there you go.
So we're going to sing a song about it and
it's really fun and we want to make sure that
the adults participate too, right?
Right?
Ok, awesome.
So, maybe you can do the hands and we'll do
the songs together.
LADY IN RED: Try to get this motion going.
Yeah, perfect.
SASHA: And at the end we need you to be really
really loud.
I'm sorry you have to be loud at the end.
Ok, here we go.
It goes like this.
[Singing]: 1-2-3 we're at the YRC. 1-2-3 we're
at the YRC.
If you want to read a book, come on in and
take a look.1-2-3 we're at the YRC.
In 5-4-3-2-1.
Storytime!
[applause]
SASHA: It's kind of a story time so let's
do one about who hear likes to travel into
space?
1 or 2.
Yeah yeah.
Ok ok.
So we'll do the same song, but we're going
to go "zoom zoom we're going to the moon."
Are you ready?
You guys can participate?
Ok.
I know you guys can sing.
Let's do it.
Ok, here we go.
[Singing]: Zoom zoom zoom we're going to the
moon.
Zoom zoom zoom we're going to the moon.
If you want to take a trip, come on up in
the rocket ship.
Zoom zoom zoom we're going to the moon.
In 5-4-3-2-1.
Blast off!
Ok, that's a little bit better.
And then what's the other one we have?
We're going to the stars.
Ok, maybe we'll go... no, what rhymes with
stars?
AUDIENCE: Mars!
SASHA: Mars?
You guys are so smart.
You've been to space a lot of times.
AUDIENCE: [ inaudible]
SASHA: How can we make a lot of noise?
CARLA: You don't get to make a noise much
in the library, so we have this big room and
we're not going to disturb anybody, so wouldn't
it be cool to make a lot of noise in the library?
SASHA: It's fun to make a lot of noise.
So, maybe we'll start with the schools that
are here.
Yeah.
What school are you guys from?
AUDIENCE: Capitol Hill Day School!
SASHA: Capitol Hill Day School and what do
we have over here?
AUDIENCE: Capitol Hill Montessori at Logan!
SASHA: Ok.
So, who's the loudest school right now?
CARLA: There you go.
AUDIENCE: We are!
CARLA: Ok, let me close the door first
SASHA: There's a little bit of a competition.
[pause]
SASHA: We're going to see who is louder.
Are you guys ready?
Ok, we have two people on each side, so we
are going to be able to tell who is blowing
our ear off stronger.
CARLA: You ladies, be the judges because they're
right in the middle.
You have a scale from 1 to 5 and so you make
the decision.
Ok.
LADY IN RED: So first we're going to see which
school can clap the loudest.
Ok?
So, let's start with this one.
On a count of three we're going to see which
school can clap the loudest, so we'll have
you guys go first.
So, 1-2-3.
[clapping]
LADY IN RED: That's pretty good.
Yeah.
I like that.
You guys up for the challenge?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
SASHA: Ok, on the count of 3-2-1.
[clapping]
LADY IN RED: That is pretty close.
Judges?
SASHA: So who thinks Capitol Hill Day School
was louder?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
SASHA: Yeah?
And who things the Montessori school was louder?
Ooh, one.
I think this was a win this time around to
you guys at Capitol Hill Day School.
So, how about who can stomp louder?
AUDIENCE: [ inaudible]
LADY IN RED: So, on a count of three, stomp
on this side.
1-2-3.
[stomping]
SASHA: It sounds like a stampede.
And stop!
SASHA: Are you guys ready?
Ok, come back with some stomps.
Let's go.
[stomping]
Some people are getting up, you're getting
into this.
All right all right.
Judges, who thinks Montessori was winning
out?
LADY IN RED: Oh, it's so close.
SASHA: Capitol Hill Day School winning out?
No?
Oh, we have a championship at the Montessori
School.
You guys are great.
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
SASHA: You guys are great.
Thank you.
CARLA: Thank you ladies, thank you because
all of that noise brought in our friends that
have been trying to get here.
Hello, glad you're here.
You could see we were making a little noise
in the library, and having fun and we hope
that all of you will have some more fun in
just a few minutes because we want to welcome
all of you to the Library of Congress.
And how many of you have been here before?
Good group, good group.
How many of you have ever stomped and made
that much noise in any library?
AUDIENCE: [inaudible]
CARLA: Okay.
Right.
All right, it could happen.
We have a number of schools that are here
with us, online, and we have a great list
of schools and they're from all over the country.
Plus, we have public schools and schools right
here in Washington DC that are looking at
us and gonna be listening online.
Could you wave at everybody?
Hey!
North Carolina, South Carolina, all of the
schools that are here and we're gonna give
'em a good shout out real soon and just say
their names.
So, I'm the Librarian of Congress, and as
you can tell, I'm a little excited about our
program today because we have a very, very
special guest.
Many of you have met him and you notice he
has a medal around his neck.
A gold medal, because he is the Librarian
of Congress' youth ambassador for young people's
literature.
And that's very similar to being an Olympic
medal winner.
He won something that's called the McArthur
Genius Award, which is really like- I know!
Yes, yes.
Now, can anybody- And I know some of you have
read his graphic books, tell me his name?
AUDIENCE MEMBER: [inaudible]
CARLA: Yes, say it loud.
CARLA: louder!
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Gene Yang.
CARLA: Yay!
And there he is.
As you know, he's gotten lots of awards, as
I just mentioned.
He's even had a chance to draw Superman.
And, if you don't know his story, he started
drawing
comic books when he was right around your
age.
And he has traveled around the country,
talking about books and reading, and reading
without walls.
And he wants everyone, and that's
what we're gonna talk about today, to read
a book that you normally wouldn't read.
How many
of you have read something, not just for school,
but a book that you look at it and you say,
"I
don't know if I really want to read this"?
Ooh, quite a few.
Well, we're gonna take the challenge.
So, I want to thank, though, some people for
making this possible.
I had to write it down to make
sure I didn't forget.
It's the Children's Book Council and Every
Child A Reader Foundation, for
their support of us being here.
Also, McMillan 1st, 2nd publishing for their
help.
So, now, I'm
gonna bring up our award winning ambassador,
Gene Yang.
[applause]
GENE: Hi, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you Dr. Hayden.
Good morning!
AUDIENCE: Good morning!
GENE: Thank you all for being here.
It's such a thrill to be in this room with
all these people who
love books.
This is like one of my favorite kinds of settings.
Well, so, the way we're gonna start this morning
off is, Dr. Hayden and I are gonna ask each
other questions, mostly about books.
Then towards the end, we'd like to get some
questions from you.
If questions pop up in your head in the beginning,
save those questions.
File them away in the back of your head, and
at the end we want to hear those questions.
What I'd like to first hear about is how you
fell in love with books.
CARLA: Well, I had the wonderful experience
of having people around me who loved to read
and one of the first things they would do
when I would go and visit my grandparents
in the summer and things, is they would read
to me.
The first thing I wanted to do though, was
learn how to read my own stuff.
It was nice being read to, I loved it, but
I couldn't wait to start reading myself, so
I could get into it and read whatever I wanted
to.
I liked crime books.
GENE: You liked crime books?
Like, books about people doing bad things?
CARLA: Yeah.
So, I found this book.
My grandmother, nice little lady and everything,
but she kind of liked mysteries and things
like that.
So, she had this book that I knew I wasn't
supposed to look at.
It was called "Hollywood Babylon."
How many of you all know what Babylon is?
It was a wild place back in the ancient days.
And Hollywood, you know where that is.
It was a true crime thing, right?
With all these gruesome pictures.
Fatty Arbuckle, just murders and stuff.
And when I would come, you know, she'd make
sure she would put it away.
And of course, I spent most of my summer finding
it.
And that's how I got hooked.
At first, I could just look at the pictures
that were really, really gruesome.
And then I want to know what it said.
GENE: That's what got you.
True crime?
CARLA: True crime.
GENE: True crime was what got Dr. Hayden into
books.
CARLA: That's what got me going.
GENE: That's great.
That's great.
For me, I grew up in a house of stories.
My parents are both immigrants.
My mom was born in mainland China.
My dad in Taiwan.
They both came to the United States for college
and met, fell in love, got married, had me.
I grew up listening to their stories.
Both my mom and my dad loved to tell stories.
I think this is actually true of a lot of
immigrant families.
A lot of parents who are from another country,
or another culture, they'll want to tell their
kids stories from that country, from that
culture, as a way of building that connection.
So, I heard lots of stories from Chinese culture
when I was a kid.
Reading, for me, was actually kind of hard.
I remember in early elementary school, my
teachers would divide us into these two groups,
right?
And they would name 'em- I think they were
named after colors.
I think one of 'em was a red group, and one
of 'em was a blue group, but really they were
the fast and slow readers.
Everybody new; the colors weren't fooling
anybody, and I was definitely always on the
slow side.
At the very end of every month, our teacher
would make us line up by how many pages we'd
read that month and I was always either last,
or second to last.
It was me and my best friend, my best friend
would trade places.
Eventually, the way I kind of got through
that was my mom would sit down and read to
me.
She would read with me.
Even now though, I'm not a fast reader.
What I realized is- you don't have to read
fast in order to love books, right?
CARLA: Right.
GENE: You just have to read.
It doesn't matter how quickly or slowly you
do it.
You can still
enjoy the book.
CARLA: Right.
And sometimes, you want to read slow so you
can get what you want out of it, or everything
like that.
GENE: Yes.
CARLA: It pains me sometimes to hear people
of your age group, and certainly in my age
group, where it made reading not fun.
GENE: Yeah.
CARLA: That's what the cool thing about reading
is, it's fun.
But to have to go through all that, it takes
a little bit from it.
GENE: Yeah, it does.
I think there are ways in which learning to
enjoy reading in the beginning can make it
so that you can get through some things that
are more difficult to read later, right?
You'll remember the fun, and that'll push
you through some of the harder stuff that
you'll have to read as you get older.
CARLA: That's why when people say, "We're
gonna read to babies and little kids and everything,"
that's to get them ready 'cause they know
there's something good if you figure out what
all this text is.
If you figure it out, you know there's a secret
in there.
There's something that's really cool in there
and it gives you that.
GENE: Yeah.
So you loved that True Crime book as a kid.
Were there any other favorites?
CARLA: I still have it.
I kept that.
GENE: Were there any other favorites?
CARLA: Oh, Little Women.
I like that.
Louisa May Alcott, and one that I brought
here today is my all time favorite when I
was a little girl, called Bright April.
It was the first book that I learned about
and you see I have my Reading Without Walls
bookmark, so take that when you get- The first
one, the Walter Award too.
The first book that I checked out over and
over and over, to the point that I had library
fines and didn't even realize it because this
book was the first book that I saw myself
in.
It was a little girl who had pigtails, who
was a Brownie, and she was brown, just like
me.
And I'm quite a bit older than you Gene.
And when I was coming up, there weren't many
books that portrayed people that looked like
me.
Much less talked about my history or anything
like that.
I just, to this day, I just love this book
because I could see myself in something that
was important, like books.
If books are important, but you don't see
yourself in 'em, what does that say?
GENE: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I had a similar issue.
It was very hard when I was a kid, to find
characters who looked like me in the books
that I was reading and in the television shows
that I was watching.
CARLA: Oh yeah.
GENE: I wonder if that's why I drifted towards
superhero comics.
I started reading superhero comics when I
was in 5th grade.
The very first superhero comic that I bought
was an issue of Superman.
It was with Superman and the Atomic Knights.
Y'all know who the Atomic Knights are?
They're a little bit more obscure, but they're
these dudes-
CARLA: There's a older gentleman.
GENE: Yes, yes.
The nerds have just outed themselves.
CARLA: That's right.
GENE: If you know who the Atomic Knights are,
you're definitely a nerd.
They're these dudes who dressed up in medieval
style armor and they ride around on these
giant, mutated dogs.
CARLA: Ew.
GENE: Yeah.
It was kind of awesome.
I gotta say it was kind of awesome.
CARLA: Okay.
GENE: I wonder if I drifted towards superheroes
because I had a hard time finding characters
who look like me.
Superheroes, people don't realize this, but
almost every major superhero out there; Superman,
Batman, Iron Man, the Hulk.
They're all created by children of immigrants.
They were all created by these sons of Jewish
immigrants from Europe.
And I think that's why every superhero has
these two identities.
I had two identities when I was a kid.
I had one name, a Chinese name that I used
at home.
I had an English name that I used at school.
I spoke one language at home, another one
at school.
It was almost like that.
It was like how Superman is both Superman
and Clark Kent.
I don't even know if I was conscious of it
as a kid, but that definitely felt really
familiar to me.
CARLA: That idea of two cultures and how you
speak and how you are at home, and how you
are outside of the home is a common theme,
I think, with a lot of cultures.
GENE: Yeah, I think that's true.
I think, I actually think that's one of the
best things about being an American, is that
you can be an American without giving up that
core piece of yourself, you know?
Because America is a collection of diverse
communities, and that's one of our strengths.
CARLA: Someone once told me when we were talking
about having and being in this country where
there's so many people looking all types of
ways.
Just this variety is, what if you only had
one type of ice cream flavor, and you could
never have anything else?
GENE: Yeah.
CARLA: Think about that.
GENE: It would be terrible.
It would be a punishment.
CARLA: You may think it's good now to just
have chocolate, but it would be a punishment
and how exciting it is to take- That's how
I feel about different types of books, too.
GENE: So, was it your love of books that led
to you becoming a librarian?
CARLA: Sure, sure.
I had musical parents and I didn't have musical
talent, so I learned early on.
But I always loved to read.
And when I found out that there was a profession,
something that you could do to introduce and
really get the excitement- I mean, look.
We're right here.
We're stomping our feet, we're talking about
Superman and we're doing all this cool stuff.
And so, when I found out about being a librarian,
I was hooked on that, too.
GENE: Was there a moment when you knew you
were gonna be a librarian?
CARLA: Yes.
There was a moment when I was working in a
store front library, similar to the one when
I found out about ...
GENE: Okay.
CARLA: Yeah, Bright April back in New York,
in Queens.
I was working with a young man named Leonard.
He was 10 and he would come in every day.
And I was kind of an apprentice, I wasn't
a librarian yet.
I hadn't even started library school, and
he would come in every day and just sit next
to me.
I would give him stuff, and he would draw
because a lot of the kids made fun of him.
And so, just knowing, and putting the right
book with Leonard, and getting him to draw
and stuff, was when I said, "Okay.
This is cool stuff."
GENE: That's great.
I do think that maybe that's a thing, too.
Maybe kids who other kids might make fun of,
often drift towards books.
I was definitely one of those kids.
I was a kid where other kids would make fun
of me, but I was also a kid who would make
fun of other kids.
I was on both sides-
CARLA: You were both.
GENE: I was a jerk.
I was definitely a jerk.
People were jerks to me and I was also a jerk
back.
CARLA: They were jerks to me and I was one
of those kids that all the, I wasn't one of
the cool ones and everything.
The last day of school, I'd have to run home
because all the cool girls would say they
were gonna beat me up.
But I could run fast.
GENE: I couldn't run fast.
CARLA: See, so you had to fight back.
GENE: Yeah.
CARLA: You had to be a jerk, too.
GENE: Yeah, I had to be a jerk, too.
But, I do think working on books, writing
and drawing, is a way of working that stuff
out.
If you have problems in your life- I think
all of us do.
Writing and drawing is a great way of just
figuring that out for yourself.
I have a friend who's an art teacher, teaches
art at a high school and he says out of all
of the classes that a kid takes in high school,
the art class is the only one where the subject
is themselves.
CARLA: Wow.
GENE: They're trying to figure themselves
out by making art.
I think that's true, not just of drawing,
but also of any kind of art, including writing.
CARLA: What about music, too?
And stuff like that.
GENE: Yeah, music too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that's why sometimes if you have things
that are painful in your life, you can find
a little bit of healing by writing and by
drawing.
CARLA: So, did you and I have to ask you this.
In drawing superheroes and things like that,
did you get any revenge?
GENE: Did I make up bad guys based on ... I
don't think I ever did it consciously 'cause
I was worried about getting in trouble, but
the very first superhero comic I did was in
fifth grade.
I did it with my friend Jeremy Kinioshi, who
was half Jewish and half Japanese.
We were both the comic book kids in our class.
During lunch when our more athletic friends
were playing tetherball- Do y'all still play
tetherball?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GENE: It's awesome, right?
Except that I was terrible at it.
The ball would always hit me in the head.
So, instead of playing tetherball, Jeremy
and I would sit at the tables and we would
draw comics together.
Then we would give our originals to his mom,
who would take 'em to work with her and wait
till all of her coworkers went home and sneak
photocopies for us.
We would take these photocopies, we stapled
them by hand to make our own comics, and we
sold our comics to our classmates for 50 cents
a piece.
It was awesome.
We made $8.
It was the best.
Nowadays, if you want to do the same thing
you cannot sell for 50 cents.
Prices have gone up.
You've gotta charge at least $1.50, but it
was great.
It was great.
I think working on that comic taught me how
to tell stories.
Working on that comic gave me a way of- I
was also a pretty shy kid, too.
It was weird, right?
Being shy and also a jerk, but I was a pretty
shy kid.
So working on that comic gave me a way of
expressing myself in ways that I couldn't
by just talking.
CARLA: How did the stories come to you?
Did you just wake up and-
GENE: Okay.
When I was in fifth grade, I thought I was
kind of like a ... I thought I was super creative
and stuff.
So, I thought, "Oh man.
I just woke up in this character form, fully
informed in my head."
But then as an adult, I look back on the character
we made up and I realize no, he was actually
just a rip off.
He was a rip off character of Robin Hood 'cause
he wore all green and he lived in the woods
and he had a band of friends that he used
to call his "Merry Men", just like Robin Hood.
CARLA: Yeah, I think that's pretty close.
GENE: Yes, isn't it?
It's a little close.
CARLA: Yeah.
GENE: But, there was one difference.
The difference was, our character, instead
of fighting with a bow and arrow, he actually
had a discus of death that he would throw
at people's heads.
CARLA: You were kind of a True Crime fantasy
stuff.
GENE: A little bit.
CARLA: Yeah, that was a little bit of-
GENE: You know, I actually think now, as an
adult, even though that one character was
terrible, I do think sometimes kids think
creativity is just like when you make stuff
up out of nothing.
But that's almost never true.
You can't make stuff up out of nothing.
What real creativity is, I think, is combining
things together that were never combined before.
So, if you love superheroes and you take something
else that you love- I don't know.
Maybe like, chocolate cake.
And you figure out a way to make a superhero
based on chocolate cake, that'll be a really
creative idea.
CARLA: Let's work on that one.
GENE: Yeah.
I agree.
CARLA: It's something, though, when you think
about.
So, what are you working on now?
What is the Reading Without Walls?
GENE: Yes.
CARLA: Don't forget the bookmarks and everything.
GENE: That's right.
Two January's ago, I was in this very room,
in January of 2016.
The Library of Congress, Every Child a Reader,
and the Children's Book Council, they gave
me this fancy medal.
To this day, this is the fanciest thing I
own.
This is as bling-bling as Gene Yang gets.
If you want to touch this, come up later.
I'll let you touch it.
It's kind of awesome.
CARLA: It's got your name engraved, too.
GENE: Yeah, it's got my name on the back.
CARLA: I see it.
Oh, cool.
GENE: Yeah, it's got my name on the back and
they named me the fifth national ambassador
for young people's literature.
Which just means that, for my two year term;
2016 and 2017, my job is to get both more
kids reading and kids reading more.
The way I'm doing that is, I've been going
around the country issuing what I call the
"Reading Without Walls Challenge."
You know, one of the best things about growing
up is you all get to explore the world.
That's your primary job right now, is to figure
out how the world works.
And books are a great way of exploring the
world, so I want us all to read books outside
of our comfort zones.
Read books that are actually exploring books.
Books that are not the normal books that we
would read.
So, the challenge works like this; you could
either do this as a community, or you can
do this just as an individual reader.
You set yourself a due date.
By that due date, just do one of three things.
Number one, you can read a book about a character
who doesn't look like you or live like you.
Somebody who's very different from you.
Two, you could read a book about a topic that
you might not know anything about.
Something that you might even find intimidating.
Or three, you can read a book in a format
that you normally wouldn't read for fun.
If normally all you read are chapter books,
I want you to give a graphic novel a try.
If normally all you read are graphic novels
and comic books, then I want you to try a
chapter book or a collection of poetry or
an audio book.
Just try lots of different kinds of stories
in different formats.
If you really want to go for the gold star,
find a book that fits all three of those categories.
I've been talking about this all over America
to different communities, and I've really
been shocked by the ways in which readers
and librarians and teachers and book store
owners have really come up and met this challenge.
It's been great.
CARLA: When I thought about you being here
and talking about Reading Without Walls and
books that I've read that, at first I thought,
"Ugh.
I don't know."
I thought about the book, Sea Biscuit.
GENE: Okay.
CARLA: Okay?
It's about a horse and I'm like, "I've only
seen in person, maybe two horses in my life,
right?"
City kid, all of this.
That wasn't it.
It's all about this horse who was an underdog
and he was a half mule, and a half this, and
nobody thought he could win.
And when I got into the book though, learned
all about horses and that, but also the spirit
of the underdog and that theme came through
and I turned into a Sea Biscuit fan, and watched
horse races.
GENE: That's great, that's great.
CARLA: 'Cause now I know a little bit about
it.
GENE: Something similar happened to me with
basketball.
As a kid, I hated basketball because I was
terrible at it.
I had these friends who were really good at
it and whenever we played, it was just like
tetherball.
The basketball would find a way of hitting
me in the head, so I hated it.
I didn't follow basketball.
I remember in college, I lived with these
guys who were huge basketball fans and we
would watch movies at home, on our VCR- Y'all
know what that is?
A VCR?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CARLA: You do?!
GENE: It's like Netflix, except you have to
have these-
CARLA: A VCR?
GENE: That you stick in.
We'd watch movies on our VCR and then when
10:30, 10:45 came around, they would force
us to pause the movie so that they could watch
sports highlights on the news.
I was always so mad about it.
But a few years ago, I started reading books
about basketball.
I read one called Outside the Paint, about
the basketball scene in 1940 San Francisco
China Town.
I read Slam Dunk.
You ever read Slam Dunk?
CARLA: I've heard of it.
GENE: It's amazing.
It's awesome.
One of the best (inaudible) series out there.
I read Matt Dellapina's Ball Don't Lie.
Read a bunch of books about basketball and
that got me really interested.
Now, I'm still not an expert.
I'm still no basketball expert.
When I watch a basketball game now, there
will still be times when all the action will
stop on the court and I'll have no understanding
of why, but at least I feel it.
You know what I mean?
I can feel the thrill of the game now and
it's because of books.
CARLA: Right, and things that you've never
experienced.
GENE: Yes.
CARLA: But really getting into it and saying,
"Okay.
I'm a try this.
I'm a try it."
GENE: Yeah.
CARLA: Now I noticed something here.
This easel with nothing on it.
GENE: Yes.
CARLA: Were you gonna put something on it?
I mean, were we gonna actually-
GENE: We can put something on it.
What I was thinking we could do, is maybe
we could design a superhero together.
Does that sound okay?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GENE: We can design a superhero together.
Okay, we'll start from the head and we'll
move down.
CARLA: Don't forget the chocolate.
GENE: Yes!
Maybe a chocolate cake superhero.
CARLA: You don't have to.
GENE: I'm gonna start by giving them a big
round head.
CARLA: Does the head have to be- Okay.
Round.
GENE: All right, big round head.
Now somebody tell me, what's on the superhero's
face?
What do you think is on the superhero's face?
Yes, young lady right there?
AUDIENCE: A mustache.
GENE: A mustache!
Okay, a mustache.
CARLA: Okay now, all right.
I have a little mustache, so-
GENE: Okay, a mustache and then what else?
What else is on his face?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: A round top hat.
GENE: A round top hat.
You all are going with some really non-traditional
superhero gear, which is fine.
Okay, so a round top hat.
CARLA: Are they pulling our legs?
GENE: A round top hat?
What else?
Tell me about this character's ears.
AUDIENCE: He should have little candles sticking
out the side of his head.
GENE: Candles?
Candles instead of ears.
Okay.
CARLA: You don't have to go with the chocolate
cake.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
We'll just have some chocolate cake later.
GENE: Okay.
Candles sticking out of the side of his head
instead of ears.
Okay, we still haven't gotten to- Somebody
tell me about his eyes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Glasses.
GENE: He has glasses.
Okay.
CARLA: Some of my older colleagues might remember
Mr. Magoo.
We kind of have a Mr. Magoo look.
GENE: All right, let's start moving down now.
Tell me about this character's body.
Yes, young lady.
AUDIENCE: A jumpsuit.
GENE: A jumpsuit.
What kind of jumpsuit?
Give me a little bit more information about
this jumpsuit.
AUDIENCE: An orange one.
GENE: Orange?
Okay, so I don't have orange.
Oh, I do!
I do have orange.
Okay, an orange jumpsuit.
Like a track suit?
Is that what you're thinking?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GENE: Like, old school, Run DMC style track
suit?
Okay, let's do this.
CARLA: Orange.
GENE: Okay, a jumpsuit.
I have actually never personally worn a jumpsuit.
So I'm not entirely positive what one looks
like.
Tell me if I do it right, okay?
Don't jumpsuits normally have like a ...
CARLA: Oh yeah.
Coming down the side.
GENE: Stripes on the side?
Is that true?
Am I making that up?
And you wanted orange?
We have red up here.
Is red close enough?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
GENE: All right, red.
We'll do red.
CARLA: Looking kind of spiffy.
GENE: All right, then somebody tell me about
his hands.
CARLA: Ooh.
GENE: Somebody tell me about his hands.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Tentacles.
GENE: What's that?
GENE: Tentacles!
CARLA: Whoo!
GENE: You sound like somebody who reads a
lot of Japanese comics.
Is that true?
There are a lot of tentacles in Japanese comics.
Okay, all right.
Let's do that.
We'll do tentacles.
I feel like we're losing out on the chocolate
cake theme here.
CARLA: But that's okay.
They can do something else.
We'll have chocolate cake later.
'Cause I want you to-
GENE: Okay, let's do tentacles on one side.
Somebody tell me about the other side.
CARLA: They can have two different?
Okay.
GENE: Yeah, there are no rules.
CARLA: No rules.
This is good.
GENE: No rules when it comes to ... Okay,
yes?
AUDIENCE: First, there's cake residue on his
face.
GENE: Cake residue on his face?
Okay.
We can do that.
CARLA: This is getting personal, people.
AUDIENCE: There are brown-
CARLA: Cake residue.
AUDIENCE: Then he has a brown sparkle shooter
thing.
GENE: Does that look like cake residue?
That looks like he just has a fungus on his
face.
Don't you think?
CARLA: Excuse me.
GENE: Okay, cake residue on his face and then
what was the other thing?
AUDIENCE: Then his hand is like, a sparkle
shooter.
It's a brown sparkle shooter thing.
GENE: A sparkle shooter?
AUDIENCE: A brown sparkle shooter.
GENE: I'm gonna guess as to what a sparkle
shooter looks like, all right?
AUDIENCE: It's a cake shooter.
GENE: Is this what a sparkle shooter looks
like?
That actually looks like dandelions.
Maybe I'll add more color and it'll look more
like a sparkle shooter.
Okay.
All right, somebody tell me about his feet.
All the way over there?
AUDIENCE: One is really big and the other
is really small.
GENE: One is really big and the other's really
small.
Good, good.
We'll do that.
Then how about his shoes?
What do his shoes look like?
Yes, young lady here.
AUDIENCE: It should be one pink and one red.
GENE: One pink and one red.
One foot is really big, and one foot's really
small.
All right.
Here's his really big foot.
It's like a clown foot.
And here's his really small foot.
And we'll do some laces.
One is pink and one is red, you said?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GENE:Okay.
All I have are red, blue, green, and purple
up here.
Is there an alternative to pink that we could
choose?
AUDIENCE: Purple.
GENE: Purple.
Got it.
Anything else you want to add?
How about a little animal sidekick?
Who would his animal sidekick be?
CARLA: Whoa.
GENE: Who would his animal sidekick be?
Yes, young lady right here.
AUDIENCE: A talking cherry.
GENE: A talking cherry?
All right.
Okay.
We'll do that.
CARLA: A cherry?
Okay.
GENE: Okay.
I think we're pretty close to being done.
CARLA: I think there's some more.
GENE: Let's do one more thing.
One more thing.
CARLA: Can they have another sidekick?
AUDIENCE: On his shoes, add cupcake boosters.
GENE: Cupcake boosters.
That's amazing.
Okay.
So, what would a cupcake booster even look
like?
It would look like-
AUDIENCE: A cupcake with jets in it.
GENE: All right.
I think we need one last thing.
We need one last thing and that is ...
CARLA: Hair.
GENE: What is his name?
What is his name?
Yes, young lady right there.
AUDIENCE: It should be ... Jeff the Weirdo.
GENE: Jack?
AUDIENCE: Jeff.
GENE: Jeff the Weirdo.
CARLA: I think that fits.
GENE: Are you mad at somebody named Jeff right
now?
AUDIENCE: Huh?
GENE: Are you mad at somebody named Jeff right
now?
AUDIENCE: No.
GENE: Okay, Jeff the Weirdo.
Jeff the Weirdo.
CARLA: Superhero.
GENE: Who is a superhero.
CARLA: Jeff would attract attention.
GENE: Weirdo is "E" before "I", right?
It's one of the few words that doesn't follow
that rule.
CARLA: Who saves the day.
GENE: How about his cherry sidekick?
What's the cherry sidekick's name?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Peep Peep.
GENE: Peep Peep?
Peep Peep.
CARLA: I'm not sure if this is gonna get optioned
for television.
I'm not sure.
Might.
GENE: All right, so I will talk to DC Comics
to see if Jeff the Weirdo and his talking
Peep Peep character can actually make their
way into the DC Universe.
No guarantees.
But I'd like you all to give yourselves a
round of applause.
That is truly a superhero like I have never
seen before.
CARLA: Never seen before.
GENE: Yeah.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: You forgot an icing cape.
GENE: An icing cape.
We'll have to add that in, in the second issue.
CARLA: Ah, the second issue.
AUDIENCE: And his symbol.
GENE: Oh yeah, and he needs a symbol.
You're right.
Those are all things that he has to earn in
issue number two.
CARLA: And that's how you develop different
issues, right?
GENE: That's how you develop different issues,
yeah.
I've written in two different environments.
I've written for graphic novels, where you
just make up a story and you tell it from,
beginning to end, all in one shot usually.
I've also worked on series, so right now I'm
working on a series called Secret Coders and
I'm working on a series for DC Comics called
New Superman, about this brand new character.
A Chinese Superman in the DC Universe.
CARLA: Cool.
Oh you're giving it a hand?
GENE: Thank you.
When you're working on a series there is this
element of making things up as you go along.
It's kind of like when I was your age and
I would tell stories.
I would just make it up as I went along.
Working on a series is like that.
CARLA: Wow.
Now the Secret Coders?
Tell me about that one.
GENE: Secret Coders is a graphic novel series
I'm doing with a friend of mine named Mike
Holmes.
Before becoming a full time cartoonist, I
taught high school computer science.
I taught kids how to code computers for 17
years.
And I've always wanted to take what I did
in my classroom and stick it into a graphic
novel series.
That's exactly what Secret Coders is.
Mike and I are trying to teach kids how to
code computers through this comic book series.
There will be six volumes in all.
Volume number three just came out.
We're really excited about it.
CARLA: Yeah.
GENE: We're super excited about it.
CARLA: How many of you know how to code, or
what coding is?
All right, very good.
GENE: A good number of you.
That's great, that's great.
Now, speaking of computers, how do you think
things are changing for the library?
CARLA: The Library of Congress, for instance,
right now you can go up on the website and
we just revamped it.
It looks much, much cooler and you can download
from thousands and thousands of photographs
in the collection of the library and use them
however you want to.
GENE: Wow, for free.
CARLA: It's really something, for free.
GENE: Download, and where are these photos
from?
CARLA: They're from everywhere.
We have photographs that tell you about history.
We have
photographs that other people have taken to
show different cultures and you can just about
type any subject in and photographs will come
that you can then download and use in any
report, in any art, any way you want to use
them.
So, that's what makes it cool.
GENE: That's great.
You don't have a favorite photo in your collection,
do you?
CARLA: Not yet.
I'm six months in and I'm discovering, so
I'm tweeting.
And every day that I'm here, I put up something
cool that I've found and I've seen.
Like Thomas Jefferson's handwriting in his
own hand when he was working on the Declaration
of Independence.
And Seeing him and what he put in, and what
he took out.
I think people don't realize there are drafts
of certain things that you hear about, but
they did a lot of cross outs and thought about
things.
And it's really nice to see, okay, this didn't
come up just perfect.
That they had to work on it.
GENE: Yeah.
I actually think that that was something that
I had to learn as I grew up and started making
stories as an adult.
When I was a kid and I read books, I always
thought, "Man, this came into that author's
head perfectly formed.
They just wrote it down and sent it to the
publisher.
The publisher made it into a book."
After I got into books, I realized that is
not the case at all.
That there's so much revision that happens.
There's so much stuff where you write something
down and you're not super satisfied with it.
You just change it and change it, and tweak
it and tweak it until it gets to where you
want it to be.
I would say maybe even half of writing, half
of making stories, is that.
CARLA: Is changing and making-
GENE: Yeah.
CARLA: So when you see that even the Declaration
of Independence, there were cross outs and
there were thoughts and there were things
like that.
And Abraham Lincoln, the Gettysburg address.
To see his whole handwriting and what he thought.
GENE: Even somebody like Abraham Lincoln couldn't
get it right the first time, right?
CARLA: Couldn't get it right the first time,
but he worked on it.
GENE: Had to go back and change it.
CARLA: And the thing about Abraham Lincoln,
that wonderful speech that he gave was the
shortest speech that day.
One guy gave a speech for three hours.
Can you imagine?
One speech, three hours.
And Abraham Lincoln got up and it was five
minutes.
They said that was the best speech of the
day because it was short and to the point.
GENE: Yeah, yeah.
Another thing that I had to learn as a professional
writer is that, often longer doesn't mean
better.
I remember when I was in high school and I
would write things for my English class, I
would always try to make my sentences as long
as possible and I would put in as many big
words as I could.
Words where I barely even understood what
they meant.
CARLA: Right.
GENE: I wanted to do it because I felt like
it would make me sound smarter.
But, now, as an adult, as a professional writer,
I realize what makes you sound smart is actually
just being clear.
If you can say something as clearly as possible,
as simply as possible, that is the best and
the smartest way of saying it.
CARLA: Have you ever ... A book that I read
in a different format, the Reading Without
Words, is a graphic novel.
A graphic march by John Lewis about the civil
rights.
GENE: Yeah.
CARLA: Oh you've read it?
Oh, good.
'Cause I hadn't ever read.
Sorry, Gene.
GENE: No, not at all.
CARLA: Never really read a graphic book and
I thought, "Oh."
Then I got into it and then I was like, "Wow,
I want volume two and volume three."
We're even thinking, and I talked to you about
that, a graphic book about the Library of
Congress.
What do you think about that?
Telling the story of the Library of Congress
in graphic format.
GENE: Yeah, I think that's an amazing book
series, March.
How many of you have read March?
Awesome.
If you haven't read it yet, you are in for
a treat.
Go and find it at your local library.
I'm sure they'll have it.
Read it.
It's a non-fiction book, so it's about real
events.
It's an autobiography.
It's Congressman John Lewis writing about
his life.
I recently visited a museum, it's called the
Toonseum.
It's out of Pittsburgh and there they have
a focus on comics art.
It's all these pages of comic book stories,
it's pages from graphic novels.
It's the originals so you can see how the
artist actually draws.
They had an exhibit there, an old comic book
that most of us don't remember, but it was
about Martin Luther King Jr and it was a 22
page comic.
John Lewis, Congressman John Lewis, when he
was a kid he read that comic book and that
comic book was so influential on him that
when it came time for him to tell his own
story about his own life, he wanted to tell
it as a comic book.
As a thick comic book, as a graphic novel.
It just goes to show that even things that
seem forgotten, like that old comic book about
Martin Luther King Jr., they're not forgotten.
When you tell stories, when you release your
own stories into the world,
you have no idea how they're gonna effect
people years down the road.
CARLA: One thing that you might not know about
the Library of Congress is that we have the
largest collection of comic books in the world,
right here.
Did you know that?
First edition of Batman, Luke Cage, all of
that.
Right here at the Library of Congress, and
we are going to display some of those things
during Awesome-Con.
GENE: Okay.
CARLA: That's gonna be here in Washington
DC with movies and comics and all of these
types of things.
And the Library of Congress is gonna be part
of Awesome-Con.
GENE: That's so great.
CARLA: We're getting there.
GENE: There's so many reasons why the Library
of Congress is awesome.
Yet another reason; largest comic book collection
in the entire world.
It looks like we're winding down, so we would
like now, to take questions from all of you.
We have a whole bunch of students joining
us from all over the country and unfortunately
those students are not gonna be able to ask
us questions.
So, I want to acknowledge that they're with
us first, and then we'll take some questions
from the kids in the room.
Okay?
Right now we're being joined by Alderman Elementary,
by Valley Springs Middle School, by St. Stevens
Elementary, Hopewell Elementary of Trinity,
Jacob's Fork Middle School, Triad Math and
Science Academy, St. Ambrose School, Norton
High, North Columbus Elementary, the College
of Education at Governor's State University,
and students from DC Public Schools all around
the city.
So, thank you all so much for joining us.
CARLA: Thank you.
GENE: So, kids in the room, what kind of questions
can we answer for you?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Okay, this question might sound
weird, but is DC Comics, is it a building
in DC?
Or is it just called DC Comics?
GENE: That is not a weird question at all
'cause DC's name is super confusing, right?
It's a weird name.
Marvel makes sense, I think.
DC Comics is a little bit weird.
DC Comics' office building used to be in New
York City.
It was in New York City for decades and decades.
Now, it's in Burbank, California, which is
just outside of Hollywood.
I got to visit the DC Comics office a couple
of times now and it's pretty awesome.
You walk into their waiting area.
They have giant statues of Superman, Batman,
and Wonder Woman, wearing the costumes that
they'll be wearing in the upcoming Justice
League movie.
They have a chess set in the middle of the
waiting room that has, instead of the traditional
chess pieces, it's like, Superman and Wonder
Woman and Batman and Joker on the other side.
Really cool.
The name DC Comics actually
comes from the very first comic book series
that DC Comics ever published.
It was called Detective Comics; it came out
in 1939.
The DC of DC Comics is actually short for
Detective Comics, which makes it a really
weird name, right?
'Cause DC Comics means it's Detective Comic's
comics.
That's just the way it is.
DC is our oldest surviving comic book company
in America.
You know, sometimes stuff from the olden days,
a little bit weird.
Yes, young lady?
AUDIENCE: For your comic books, do you have
a person who helps you have ideas for them,
or is it just you by yourself having the ideas
for your books?
GENE: The question is, do I just have ideas
on my own, or do I have somebody helping me
with ideas?
I would say it depends on the book.
So, when I'm writing for DC Comics, the stories
that I'm writing are part of a bigger universe.
Right now, I'm writing about a character called
Kennan Kong, who is the Chinese Superman.
Kennan Kong is in the same universe as Clark
Kent, as Bruce Wayne, as all the other superheroes.
In that case, I can't just have ideas on my
own.
I actually have to collaborate with other
artists and with other writers.
Then when I write books for my other publisher,
1st, 2nd Books, most of those are stand alone
graphic novels.
They're a story with a beginning, middle,
and end.
For those, I generally just have ideas on
my own.
Sometimes I'll work with a partner, but often
they'll start off as just in my own head.
All right, that sounds like a question from
somebody who might be wondering where ideas
come from.
Is that true for you?
Okay.
So, I get this question a lot.
Kids will sometimes ask me where my ideas
come from.
Often, my ideas come from my own life.
Sometimes, if you feel like you have a creative
assignment and you don't have any ideas for
it, just think about your own life.
Even if your own life seems boring, I guarantee
if you think about it long enough, it is not.
For instance, the very first comic I ever
did as an adult is called Gordon Yamamoto
and the King of the Geeks.
It's about a young man who gets a space ship
stuck inside of his nose and becomes friends
with the alien that's living inside of the
ship.
That book is from my own life.
CARLA: Tell us how.
GENE: I have always had sinus problems.
CARLA: Oh, okay.
GENE: I've always had sinus problems and one
day I thought, "What if what was plugging
up my nose was a space ship?"
Think about your life long enough.
I guarantee you, ideas are gonna come out.
CARLA: I need that now.
GENE: Yes?
AUDIENCE: How did you feel when you released
your first book?
GENE: How did I feel?
The very first book that I released was in
fifth grade.
It was amazing.
AUDIENCE: When you were a grown up?
GENE: As a grown up, the first book that I
released was Gordon Yamamoto and the King
of the Geeks.
I actually self-published that, so I didn't
even go through a publisher.
I just got it printed up myself and I'd try
to go to stores and local comic book conventions
to sell it by hand.
It was great.
It was a lot of work.
It's a lot of work to publish your own comic,
but I remember being at a comic book convention
and handing that book to somebody, and having
them hand me a few dollars.
It felt great that somebody wanted to read
my book so much that they were willing to
part with three dollar bills for it.
It was awesome.
Yes, young man in the front?
AUDIENCE: When did you make your first comic
book?
GENE: When did I make my first comic?
The very first comic I remember making was
in fifth grade.
Was that, the main character was a rip off
of Robin Hood.
It was a terrible comic, but it was still
fun to make.
CARLA: Anybody in the middle?
AUDIENCE: Do you have any more copies of the
books that you had from when you were younger?
GENE: Do I have any more copies?
I'm sure if I went back to my parents' house
and I dug around, I'd be able to find one.
Yeah, of that fifth grade comic.
I also, when I was in sixth grade, I made
a comic about somebody who sold shoes.
I don't even know what I was thinking.
I made a comic about somebody who sold shoes
and I made a comic about ... Do you know what
the Smurfs are?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GENE: And you know what the Transformers are.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GENE: I made a comic called the TransSmurfers,
where all the Smurfs would transform into
robotic fruit.
That was fun to work on.
CARLA: Okay.
GENE: Yes?
AUDIENCE: This isn't really related to your
book, but what's your favorite basketball
team, if you like basketball?
GENE: Okay, the question is what is my favorite
basketball team?
I want to hear yours.
I come from the Bay area, so there's only
one answer, right?
I have to go with the Warriors.
CARLA: I'm from Chicago.
GENE: Yeah.
There you go.
CARLA: Drop the mic.
Da Bears.
Oh, that's football.
GENE: How about the young lady right there
in the- Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What materials do you use to make
your comics?
GENE: I'm sorry, what was that?
AUDIENCE: What materials do you use-
GENE: What materials?
That's great.
So, when I was your age, I read this book
called How to Make Comics the Marvel Way.
It was written by Stan Lee and Stan Lee told
me I had to use a certain set of materials.
Told me I had to use Bristol board, which
is like this super thick, white paper.
Really, really thick.
He told me I had to use a certain kind of
pencil.
He told me I had to use a brush and a bottle
of ink.
So I did; that's how I started off making
comics.
Then after I became an adult.
After I started going to conventions and hanging
out with other cartoonists, I realized that
not everybody makes comics the Marvel way.
Almost every cartoonist you talk to, they
will have figured out their own set of materials.
So, if you want to make comics, if you want
to make are in general, you should experiment.
You should figure out what materials feel
best for you.
Right now, I am using a regular number two
pencil to draw.
I'm using what's called a "blue pencil" to
do my sketching.
It's a certain shade of blue called "non-photo
blue" and I no longer ink with a brush and
a bottle of ink.
I actually ink with a Japanese brush pen.
I don't need that bottle of ink anymore.
Yes?
Young lady with the headband?
AUDIENCE: What is your Chinese name?
GENE: My Chinese name?
So, my Chinese name is- My American name is
a transliteration of my Chinese name, meaning
my parents picked my American name because
it sounded kind of like my Chinese name.
My American name is Gene Luen Yang.
My Chinese name is Yang Ging Luen.
Now that middle character, Ging, has an interesting
story behind it.
It's a Chinese tradition to give the gift
of gold to babies when they're first born.
When I was first born, I got all this gold
from my relatives.
Then after I became an adult, my mom gave
me this gold.
When I got this gold as an adult, I looked
through it and on one of these little plates,
it had my name.
It had Yang Ging Luen, but the middle character,
Ging, was a different character.
It sounded the same, but it was a totally
different word.
I was like, my aunt who gave this to me, she
didn't even know my name.
She got my name wrong.
My mom said, "No.
She didn't get it wrong.
That was your actual name when you were first
born."
I said, "Okay, so what does this Ging mean?"
She says, "That Ging means splendid."
I said, "It means splendid?
You name me Splendid?
Why did you change that?"
She said, "Well after you turned one and you
started walking around, you kept hitting your
head.
We changed it to another Ging, which means
careful."
That's what my name means now in Chinese.
It means careful.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How many comics have you made since
you started?
GENE: So, the question is, how many comics
have I made since I started?
I have made a lot.
It's actually kind of hard to count.
I did 10 issues of Superman.
I'm working on issue number 13 of New Superman,
so right there I've done 23 issues for DC
Comics.
And then for 1st, 2nd, I've done a lot.
I've maybe done ... I don't know.
12 books now?
Then I have also worked on the Avatar Last
Air Bender comics.
I did 15 volumes of that so far, so I've done
a lot.
CARLA: Wow.
GENE: Yes, young man in the ...
AUDIENCE: What's your favorite book?
Comic book?
GENE: My favorite book when I was a kid ... I'm
really sad that it's been a little bit forgotten,
so I want you all to try to read this book
today.
I love the Book of Three.
It's a series of books by Lloyd Alexander.
They were my favorite.
As a librarian, you must've seen that go out
a lot, right?
CARLA: Lord.
GENE: My generation loved that book.
It seems like-
CARLA: It's been lost-
GENE: It's been a little bit lost-
CARLA: But it's really cool.
GENE: I'm trying to bring it back.
CARLA: Good.
Lloyd Alexander, classic.
GENE: Yeah, I love Lloyd Alexander.
Then in terms of comic books, you know March
is a really great comic book.
You all ought to read that.
There's just a ton of comic books that I love.
I don't know if I could pick one favorite.
I really do love Mouse, though.
It's a little bit older.
It's a non-fiction book about the Holocaust.
It's a really sad, and heart wrenching book,
but I think it's brilliantly done.
CARLA: Then I have a question.
Go ahead.
GENE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What was the first book that the
Library of Congress had in their library?
GENE: That's a great question.
Wow!
I want to know, too.
CARLA: I don't know.
The first book.
There were about two or three hundred books
in 1800.
The Library was actually part of the capital.
They had books like the Bible and some other
books that they thought that it would be good-
Dictionaries and things that they thought
it would be good for Congress.
Thank you for asking that 'cause I'm gonna
find out, what was the very first book that
someone purchased for the library.
GENE: That's great.
Can you give us some of the highlights of
the collection?
CARLA: Oh my goodness.
Highlights.
Well, you have books that go back to the 12th
Century.
You have the first Bible, right outside here,
that was ever printed with type.
So the Gutenberg Bible.
That was something- 1500.
Then you have books that you would call them
"graphic" now.
Audubon books with the beautiful birds and
all types of things.
There's so many things.
That's what's so wonderful about it.
GENE: Yeah.
It's a magical place.
You all feel the magic, right?
Sitting in this room?
CARLA: Well, we were stomping around.
GENE: Young man in the red.
AUDIENCE: Earlier you were telling me and
my friends about Frog Man, so-
GENE: Oh yeah.
CARLA: Frog Man?
GENE: Yeah, earlier we were hanging out and
they were asking me what my favorite superhero
was.
And Frogman is definitely one of my favorite
superheroes.
He's an obscure character from the Marvel
universe.
He doesn't have any super powers; he just
wears a costume that makes him look like a
frog.
So, his whole thing is this; he is the son
of a super villain named the "Leap Frog",
who would use his frog suit to go and rob
banks.
Then he finds out that his dad is this criminal
and he feels really bad about it, so he steals
the suit from his dad and becomes a superhero
called "Frog Man".
CARLA: And his super powers are?
GENE: His super powers, at the bottom of his
suit, on each of his feet, are giant springs.
He can just jump around and that's his whole
power.
Yeah.
CARLA: I'm learning a lot.
It's good.
GENE: Yep?
AUDIENCE: Do you write and illustrate your
books, or does somebody else do it?
GENE: Do I write and illustrate my books?
It depends on the book.
So, there are some books where I do both the
writing and the drawing, and there are other
books where I only do the writing and somebody
else does the drawing.
I work with a friend of mine who does the
drawing.
So it depends on the book.
CARLA: Do we have time for a couple more questions?
One more question.
Oh my.
GENE: One more question.
Okay.
How about the young lady with the sunglasses?
AUDIENCE: Do you prefer Marvel or DC Comics?
GENE: I'd like to hear your- Do you have an
answer to this, Dr. Hayden?
CARLA: No.
I'm just getting into it.
Between Frog Man, Jeff the Weirdo, and some
of the others, I have to start reading and
this is gonna be my Reading Without Walls.
I'm gonna get into real comic books.
That's my pledge.
GENE: I'm gonna have to send you some.
CARLA: I'm going to read, and this is my reading
challenge and it's gonna be fun 'cause I'm
a go in the comic store.
They're gonna say, "What is she doing in here?"
I'm a go in the comic store and I'm a pick
out some Marvel comics- Any suggestions besides-
GENE: From Marvel Comics?
Ms. Marvel.
Ms. Marvel is great.
Yeah, it's the ... It's a Muslim American
young girl who has the power to make any part
of her body as big or as small as she wants.
CARLA: I can use that.
GENE: She makes it super big.
It's awesome.
CARLA: Or super small?
GENE: Then Totally Awesome Hulk.
That's another one.
CARLA: Okay, and then DC Comics?
GENE: Then DC, Batgirl is amazing.
It's awesome.
Batgirl is a wonderful comic, and Supergirl
is also a wonderful comic.
CARLA: Okay.
Do they have any librarian comic characters?
GENE: Are there any librarian comic characters?
There was one called The Answer, which is
about a librarian who becomes best friends
with a superhero.
CARLA: I'm a look for that one, too.
That's my Reading Without Walls.
I pledge that I will go and get some real
comics.
GENE: That's great.
CARLA: My question for you too, when we talk
about graphic novels, what about non-fiction.
What do you call them?
Because a novel seems to be fiction.
GENE: Yes.
CARLA: A book like March is a graphic book?
GENE: Yeah, I agree.
To answer that young lady's question, for
me, nowadays because I write for DC I'm kind
of a DC guy.
But when I was a kid, when I was your age,
I read more Marvel than DC.
The term "graphic novel" is a little bit clumsy,
right?
We use it to describe things that actually
aren't novels at all like March.
March is ...
CARLA: It's real.
GENE: It's not a novel, it's non-fiction.
It's an autobiography.
The New York Times deals with this by calling
them "graphic books" instead of graphic novels,
but I do think that the term graphic novel,
even though it's a little bit weird, it refers
to a publishing format.
CARLA: Okay, rather than what type of-
GENE: Rather than what type, yes.
CARLA: Okay.
GENE: All right.
It looks like we're just about out of time.
I want to thank all of you who are in this
room-
CARLA: Thank you.
GENE: And those of you who are joining us
through the cameras.
Thank you so much for being here.
It was wonderful to talk to you all.
Thank you.
Thank you all so much.
CARLA: Now who gets to take Jeff the Weirdo
home?
GENE: How are we gonna decide that?
CARLA: I don't know.
How do you do that, where you do a thing and
you just-
GENE: We'll do this.
We'll do a trivia challenge.
Somebody tell me- I mentioned this earlier.
Somebody tell me, when did Superman debut?
When was issue ... When was his first comic
published?
CARLA: And don't look it up.
GENE: The young man in the Dragon Ball Z.
You remember?
AUDIENCE: 1938.
GENE: Close.
Very close, but not quite right.
Okay.
AUDIENCE: Around the 1930s.
GENE: It is the 1930s.
I want an exact number.
Go ahead young lady.
AUDIENCE: 1939.
GENE: Close.
Very close.
Over here, yes.
AUDIENCE: 1933.
GENE: No, very close.
AUDIENCE: 1939.
GENE: No.
CARLA: In the back, over there-
AUDIENCE: 1931.
GENE: 1931?
Okay, young lady right there with the headband.
Close, so close.
AUDIENCE: 1937?
GENE: That's right.
1937.
All right.
So you get Jeff the Weirdo.
CARLA: And you're the one that, you get Jeff
the Weirdo 'cause you thought about his side
kick, the cherry, Peep Peep.
GENE: Yeah, that's right.
You were the one that made up the talking
cherry.
CARLA: You have to get that.
Thank you, Gene.
GENE: Thank you so much.
CARLA: Thank you so much.
GENE: This is wonderful.